hey guys what's up this is andrew from
chainsenses.com so yesterday i did an
update about amc today is gamestop so we
don't we didn't have a good closing day
for the week it was actually pretty bad
so let's check everything that we have
here the price action the news try to
understand what could have happened in
this market and see what might happen
next so let's get into it
[Music]
all right damn stuff here we go so as
you guys know i post daily updates about
amc and gamestop on discord
i hope this is helpful and here let's
first check on the daily time frame
i was expecting a second with pullback
okay for the past two three days i'm
saying all right guys it's looking good
because we have this uh we had this move
up here we had a small fake out above
the blue trend line
okay but still i was saying careful the
second wave fullback might come and it
came but let's be honest i didn't expect
that at all i was expecting 178 to hold
and it was pretty much the highest level
we saw on friday so that's not good we
had this gap down
so this is still valid i mean you know
this is the county i'm having for the
past weeks i still believe this is
correct
we have a second wave that is
above the beginning of the first wave
which level was 165 and here the low was
168 roughly so we still have a potential
one two then we have a very strong
support and it's a bit like amc those
two they are back in the same situation
so it's gonna be once again very
interesting to see what's happened what
happens next monday i'm showing you this
amc quickly we have this triangle that i
was not doing before but now it's kind
of obvious that we have this triangle
here
so
let's see about the labeling but it
might be an abcde and not a wxy so let's
see but guys the stop is exactly the
same so now
we are back in the same situation so i
don't know yet if it's if this triangle
is finished or not if it's a one two or
not it's it doesn't really matter guys
all right
if you want i can get rid of that this
is just helping me to see on the short
term which direction we are going by
checking if we have an impulse or not
for example when you have a very strong
move like this
uh this is impulsive so this usually is
uh bullish here it didn't follow so then
we have the second wave but then we
should have a third wave so you know
this is the kind of signals that i'm
trying to use to know which camp is
leading but on those stocks nc gamestop
and even all the other mean stocks
there are a lot of fake outs a lot of
fake outs a lot of fault signals
so it's more tricky but you still have
some good
reactions
on some levels for example here we
arrive right on the trend line that is
connecting the lows here and here which
is at 167 and on the 200 day moving
average as you guys can see it's the
first time we tested first time we
tested what about amc amc it's further
so we have more room but on gamestop
it's the first time we test it and you
guys know that the 200-day moving
average is very followed by big money
players like asset managers even some
hedge funds
so what could happen here is just that
those guys are buying yesterday we had a
small bounce from here
so it acted as support yesterday already
and let's see what is happening we need
to understand why we had those moves
down and the only reason i find because
once again there are some news but no
major news
is that what is the volume traded here
so on gamestop we traded 3 million
shares around 170 so it's like
about 4.5
500 million us dollar guys for market
cap like game stuff around 20 bill 20
billion it's not a lot all right amc
traded around 1.5 billion because it's
45 million shares
at 30 so 1.2 billion roughly 1.3
so total less than 2 million because on
my discord everybody is talking about
that
once again for me it's impossible to
trade those you know i would really
recommend to stay away but you can't uh
just ignore those crazy stocks so we
have
d-w-a-c
p-h-u-n and
m-a-r-k okay those three stocks they are
making crazy moves okay we're talking
here about
500 percent
for phun 100 for the dw ac and 140
percent for mark
and if we check the volume traded guys
it's about so here 100 million times 100
so 10 billion
okay
for dwac
here
600 million
so 5 billion so we have already 15
billion and this one
200 million
okay so this one has half a billion
so you can see guys that all the money
was in those stocks yesterday i mean on
friday and we didn't have volume on gm
amc and we have no news and we have
massive moves down so what this means to
me
it means that we have a rotation from
those stocks
to you know those two cra two three
crazy ones okay from nc game stuff and
all the other minion stocks they got
hammered i mean ata pizza all of them
they got silverbee sold on friday and i
think the money just went in those two
or three so whenever this would
go and i don't believe this would you
know be something that happens for the
long run the money will come back to
meme stocks right because money needs to
find a home as you guys know so i think
this is just temporary i
really believe that this distraction
created a big uh outflow of money for
the usual meme stocks
and that when things would be back to
normal the money would flow again in
those but we need this money quickly
guys let's be honest because we don't
want to see
a move below
the 165 level this would not look good
at all so what is my scenario from here
i'm bullish guys i mean you know i
believe in it so i think we're gonna
have a bounce from here
then probably reject it and then let's
see but we need to be aware that there
is an alternative scenario where we
break okay so what would happen if we
break this as for amc guys i think the
situation would be same and we would go
to one of those triangles okay
so either this one
you know we would still have a triangle
but just the bases would not be inclined
it would be horizontal and we would
probably go
find support at one of those lows okay
so either 145
150
130
120 we have a lot so that's good guys
it's just like uh whenever
you know stock got hammered heavily
there are a lot of back holders that
will exit whenever the price is higher
in this situation
it's not backholders that we have we
have bulls that are not satisfied
because they didn't buy enough shares
and this is what would create those
reactions at any of those support levels
so once again for now we are like this
guys we are looking good i mean we're
looking back on the short term but we're
looking good on the
medium term and we have this here
support level that is coming so as long
as we stay above that everything looks
great guys let's quickly have a look at
sorry at the option market i'm not going
to spend too much time here because you
guys know that already but let's just
check what we have
i just want to see if the bullish
momentum
is not failing on the upside okay
but better 20
of maximum synthetic shorts so buyers
are here guys and as you guys know they
come oh we have the 300 strike quite big
as well
so
and what maturity is it coming from so
this is all the option data that comes
from bloomberg and that shows me where
investors put their money
and they put the money so i'm checking
the maturity
okay so mostly gen 22 but we have
already 10 000 options so times 100 for
shares on the gen 23 and it's mostly
coming from gen 22 so i'm going to keep
an eye on this
november whoa okay
oh this is the 800.
the big one is here guys
i don't see it here okay sorry done
let me do that again
okay
okay
but i was missing some strikes
so right now i have the 900 strike where
is it
it's here okay and this is the biggest
one okay
and it's still coming from gen 2. so
what i'm interested in is to see when we
approach giant 22 if we have a role
of options to jump in three if yes this
means that bears won't win i mean we
have one more year with still the big
inflow inflows of money coming from the
government from the federal reserve to
sustain the economy so this is this
money that creates those squeeze guys
you need to be aware of that so as long
as we are in this environment of free
money and
as long as we see this money flowing
into amc and stuff this is very bullish
and this is the reason why i believe the
squeeze i mean the big squeeze might
eventually happen so that's it for today
i hope you guys enjoyed this video and
if you did please don't forget to click
on the sub like and bell button so
you're going to be the first to know
when i upload anything new and stay
close to shore see you guys